106 house republicans
have joined the texas lawsuit which has
also been joined by 17
other states and the president of the
united states
to reverse the certification on the 2020
presidential election
we are getting down to the wire the
electors will vote
within days is there time there is hope
there is momentum but is there time
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knoll show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday from rammus's
who says if women who voted for trump
are no longer women does that mean that
trump won the trans vote too that's a
great
point it would be the same thing for
black people right
biden famously said if you don't vote
for me you ain't black
so the black guys who voted for trump
and there were many of them trump made
inroads among the black vote
uh those guys are not black therefore
they're transracial like rachel dolezal
so trump is making huge inroads here
this is one of the issues with leftist
identity politics
is uh you only count
among the aggrieved victim group if you
do exactly what the left says
so it it uh it it's it is always an
incoherent sort of ideology
but when you add the trans to the mix of
it it becomes impossible
even to fathom big news today is 106
house republicans are joining this
lawsuit so we've discussed the various
legal challenges to the 2020 election
and i thought some were better
challenges than others i thought that
pennsylvania challenge was stronger
because
pennsylvania obviously violated their
state constitution with their election
practices
this case is a little more unusual in
that you have one state
suing other states over the state's
election
practices because there was clear
evidence of crooked election practices
going on in those states well how does
texas have the right to do that
because obviously if other states are
cheating at the presidential election
that will change who the president is
going to be or
if that does change who the president is
then that obviously will affect
texas as well we haven't seen a lawsuit
like this
before also why does it go to the
supreme court because when states sue
other states
then the supreme court has original
jurisdiction there
as a legal matter seems like it's more
of a long shot as a political matter
though there's a ton of support
when you've got now 18 states and the
president and 106
house republicans there's a lot of
political pressure on the court even if
there's less
legal pressure rather we will know
very shortly it may happen while this
show is on uh
because the the supreme court is going
to decide i believe today
somehow republicans are not joining that
lawsuit chip roy is one of them and i
don't want to attack chip roy because i
think chip roy actually has pretty good
reasoning here
i do support the legal challenge i do
support the texas lawsuit
and the house republicans who are
supporting it and the other states as
well
and the president but i think chip roy
makes a good point what he says is
today a number of my colleagues will be
filing an amicus brief
in support of the by the way there's
some there's some disagreement over how
to pronounce amicus or amicus i
being a swarthy person from the
continent and
italy prefer amicus but do as you wish
in support of the lawsuit filed by the
state of texas regarding the election
results of several other states
respectfully i will not join because i
believe the case itself
represents a dangerous violation of
federalism and sets a precedent to have
one state
asking federal courts to police the
voting procedures of other states
this to me seems like a pretty legit
reason to not join this lawsuit because
you know
the result of this if the election were
to go the other way is you'd have
liberal states
suing conservative states for perfectly
legitimate voting practices
like requiring a voter id
and while i'm more than willing to have
the battle on the standards themselves
while i'm more than willing to say
it is good to have laws that require
voter id
it is bad to have crooked election
officials in georgia
illegally counting their votes to the
wee hours of the morning after they sent
poll workers home i'm totally willing to
have that debate
but this would be unprecedented this
would would be something that we haven't
seen before
and probably in in the short to medium
term
it would not work out very well in our
favor so i
i understand that i'm still willing to
take the risk
i'm still willing to back the texas
lawsuit
but i don't i this is not an issue where
where i want to castigate
republicans who are uneasy about it
because i don't think it's just a matter
of the hardliners and the squishes
in terms of supporting this particular
lawsuit and as a
legal matter i i just don't see it
happening if the supreme court wasn't
willing to hear the strong case
i'm not sure they're willing to hear
this case which is which is just not
quite as strong
some people disagree however country
star john rich
is now betting 10 000 dollars
that the supreme court will intervene
and hand the 2020 presidential election
to donald trump 10 grand that's pretty
good i mean i like the
fervor i like the encouragement i like
the support i don't want us to give up
or concede one single thing until the
electors vote
i probably would not put ten thousand
dollars up there one of the reasons i
would not
is because the left
believes they've won it the left is now
totally convinced the strongest evidence
i've seen
of this yet from the daily beast
daily beast writes the seeds of hunter
biden's current legal woes
were found on his laptop
december 9th 2020 the daily beast
is breaking the story about hunter
biden's laptop
which had incriminating information
about his business practices and
personal habits
that story broke in october
but a lot of people didn't hear about
that story breaking in october
because the left-wing media and
big tech most especially covered it up
they actively suppressed the story
they wouldn't let you share the story
they wouldn't let you send the story in
a private message
they knew the story would damage biden
there was a media research center poll
that showed that biden gained something
like 14 points
because people didn't know about the
hunter biden story the story of the
biden family corruption
14 of people who voted for biden
according to this one poll said that
they would not have voted for biden had
they known that
and now the left these cynics
and psychopaths will look you right in
the face and say wow can you imagine
this
can you admit look hunter biden has
legal troubles quote
evidence of a money laundering probe
into hunter biden
was apparent in the markings on a series
of documents that were made public
but went largely unnoticed in the days
leading up
to the november election when
why why did it go largely unnoticed
because you active you can't claim
ignorance you can't claim that you
wanted to research it more
you were actively suppressing this
information
now you think that the election is so
beyond
decided that you can come out with this
information
why why leak it now some people think
it's to damage biden because people want
to help
kamala harris a little bit more but
regardless i don't think you even need
to go that far they're doing it because
they think they've already got it
wrapped up and frankly they very well
may
this is what trump has been up against
the whole time he's been up against
obviously the democratic party obviously
the bureaucracy
the media hollywood big technology
that whole blob has been
actively conspiring against them you
can't say it's just an accident after
reading the daily beast article
that is an active conspiracy
there is some good news though if biden
is going to be named the president
the trump administration is going full
pedal to the metal in these final days
including
attempting to break up facebook that's
very important you know our country
has been confronted with unprecedented
perils as edmund burke put it
all it takes for evil to prevail is for
good people to do nothing
and if you want to help preserve america
while we still can join amac the
association
of mature american citizens the fastest
growing conservative group in america
joining amac gives you access to money
saving benefits cutting edge news
and a great bi-monthly magazine more
importantly
amac fights for you
a socialist storm is brewing okay
you can see it they think it's happening
right now and this
ain't going to be a moderate for years
if it turns out the way it's looking
it's going to be a radical four years if
you care about our future
then join amac today over two million
conservatives have already joined amac
stand with amac right now go to amac
dot u s slash knowles k w l e s a
m a c dot u s slash knowles k w l e s
the benefits of a mac membership are
great but the cause is even greater
join today in act.us knowles
the trump administration is moving to
break up facebook excellent news
the federal government and 48 attorneys
general
filed twin lawsuits against facebook on
wednesday
seeking to potentially break up the big
tech giant and restrict
future business practices the federal
trade commission is here
attorneys general from 46 states plus dc
plus guam
are challenging specifically the way
they're challenging this is facebook's
acquisition of instagram
in 2012 and 2014. uh when the 2014 they
acquired whatsapp these lawsuits are
trying to
force facebook to notify the federal
government of any acquisitions worth 10
10 million or more they're
not just pursuing section 230 the way
that facebook and other big tech giants
have abused a special legal protection
that they have from a 1990s era internet
law
though they should do that too they're
not just pursuing fraud the way that
that facebook and big tech have been
able to
get a critical mass in the public square
they're also going after them
with antitrust they're also going after
them for acquiring companies in a way
that's that's illegal this is good news
glad to see there's a little bipartisan
support here
uh we need to do it the only
conservative and really more of a
libertarian argument against going after
facebook
and i think it's weak even on
libertarian grounds but the only
argument is well
if you allow the government to
police facebook then the left might
start censoring
you like they're already doing
through facebook
okay i think if the risk is so right now
here's the plus side here's the pros for
breaking up facebook facebook is
censoring us and they probably threw a
presidential election to the left
by actively suppressing very relevant
serious news that even the left is now
admitting serious
because it won't affect their electoral
prospects
so the pros are we can
stop those people from throwing
elections to the left and the con
is by empowering the government to do
this and power they already have
uh the left might censor us and suppress
us and tilt elections in their favor so
there's no risk whatsoever
all the reason to do it and i applaud
the trump administration for doing that
i hope we can
get that going quickly there
is another great thing that the
president has done
this is a little more controversial but
it happened last night i just want to
touch on it because it's been trending
all over the internet
the trump administration is speeding up
executions
of people who have been on death row
some of them for 20 years or more
and they're speeding them up because joe
biden wants to let all these criminals
off the hook
last night they killed this guy brandon
bernard brandon bernard was convicted in
the year 2000
of abducting and robbing two youth
pastors who had offered him a ride who
had actually done him a favor
uh robbed them stuffed them in a trunk
drove all around for hours
sold their wedding rings and things like
that tried to pawn off all their goods
then as they were begging for mercy and
begging for their lives and reading the
bible
he his buddies this whole group of guys
shot them
uh to death but the woman actually
didn't die yet and then brandon bernard
set the car on fire and she burned alive
that guy has to be executed by the state
if if criminal justice has any meaning
at all that guy's got to be executed
there was a last-minute call
including from people on the right to
give him a pardon or delay his execution
that is a bad idea he
rightly was executed as quickly as
possible
given the circumstances and may god have
mercy on his soul i think some people
have the wrong impression
that i am bloodthirsty for the death
penalty i'm eager i love the death
penalty i'm so
thrilled when the death penalty happens
i do in a sense i guess i love the death
penalty i
i love it in that i i know that the
state
must exact justice that is the role of a
state
but i don't get giddy you know when
criminals
are killed that that's not the issue
i am pleased when justice is done
because justice
must be done in this system i have no
personal
ill will toward this guy brandon bernard
apparently
he turned his life around while in
prison you know and kind of
death row really did something for him
and it really changed his mind and
i don't know his religious thinking by
the end of his life but he really did
turn around that's not an argument
against the death penalty that's an
argument for the death penalty because
the death penalty obviously is
retributive
the death penalty is obviously deterrent
and apparently the death penalty is
rehabilitative too
because this guy facing his own
mortality
turned his life around that's very good
and so
the appropriate response to this sort of
thing is not to say
that vicious awful terrible people who
commit awful vicious terrible crimes
like monsters
should get off the hook that's not the
answer that's extraordinarily
unjust and there is a role for mercy in
a in a civil society
but there is not a role to
to have no justice whatsoever that would
be great that would be a perversion of
society
so that's not the risk and the response
is also not yeah go get i'm so glad
you're being killed
the response is the guy committed this
crime and in certain particular heinous
crimes
must meet with the ultimate penalty
and we should pray for his soul it's a
good thing
it's a good thing for everybody involved
a materialist culture doesn't quite
understand that
but that is a good thing there's a guy
that's going to be executed today
hopefully
we all hope uh because there's probably
going to be another push to get him off
the hook too
he uh sexually abused his two-year-old
daughter and then tortured her and
killed her
because she knocked over her training
potty that guy
obviously has to die i don't by the way
i don't think there's evidence that he
has had any particular change of heart
i think he remains unrepentant i could
be wrong about that it doesn't really
matter either way
that guy must be executed quickly and we
should pray that god have mercy on his
soul
capital punishment is pro-life a society
has the right to defend itself
simple as that a society has the right
to exact justice
that is pro-life it is
it's it's a fact that people exact
justice
and sometimes even engage in war for
peace right the purpose of these things
is peace and sometimes they get a little
bit off
but we are getting on the domestic front
we're finally restoring a bit of justice
to the system
and then on the foreign policy front
which has been so bellicose in america
so warmongering for a long time
especially under barack obama that
we now have a little piece abroad
president trump has another
huge peace deal in the middle east who
would have guessed that trump would
bring peace to the middle east
it's really big and nobody's covering it
in the mainstream media
and it helps me sleep well at night you
know what else helps me sleep well at
night
my pillow you know mike lindell you've
seen him on a lot of conservative media
he's a great guy and i look i would
support his company just because i like
him
but then i tried my pillow his stuff is
unbelievable
i love it i had nice fancy expensive
pillows before that i don't use them
anymore
i only use my pillow best pillow i've
ever used the pillows don't go flat i
don't know how but they don't you can
wash and dry them as many times as you
want
they maintain their shape best of all
they're made in the united states
if you don't have a my pillow or know
someone who doesn't
now is the time because for a limited
time
mike is offering his premium my pillows
for his lowest price ever you get a
queen size premium my pillow which is
regularly 69.98
for only 29.98 that is a 40 savings
christmas right around the corner uh
king size pillows are only five bucks
more
now is the time to buy not only are you
getting the lowest price ever they're a
terrific gift
29.98 for a queen size premium my pillow
uh mike also is going to extend his
60-day money-back guarantee
to march 1st 2021. doesn't matter he
could extend it to march 1st 2025 you're
not going to want to return this pillow
go to mypillow.com and click on the
radio listener square
there you will find not only this
amazing offer but also
deep discounts on all my pillow products
including the giza dream
bed sheets the my pillow mattress topper
and my pillow towel sets
you can also call 800 651 1148
and use promo code daily wire
trump great peace deal between israel
and morocco they've agreed to full
diplomatic relations this is a massive
breakthrough for peace in the middle
east this is a total rebuke
of the democratic establishment foreign
policy we were told by john kerry he
said
you will not get peace in the middle
east unless you deal with the
palestinian problem in israel
you want he said i promise you there's
no way it's not possible
guess what guess what president trump
ignored the so-called palestinian
problem he went directly to the other
arab nations
and brokered peace between them and
israel how many times now i've lost
count
at how many peace deals in a just world
president trump would receive the nobel
peace prize several times over
but he won't because the nobel peace
prize is a joke
as his time person of the year by the
way which just went to uh
uh joe biden and kamala harris they've
now they now have the distinction of
sharing an award that hitler received
that's not fair other people
we've all received the time person of
the year if you count 2006
but these awards are frivolous
because when you the disconnect all you
have to do is read the daily beast
the disconnect between the way that the
liberal establishment
reports and recognizes things and the
reality of that
of of what's actually being done is
vast andrew cuomo the deadliest governor
with regard to covid
just won the teddy kennedy award for
leadership
i kid you not the ted which is actually
pretty fitting
i wonder if andrew cuomo's victims will
receive the mary jo kopecky award
for covered up political scandals
andrew cuomo didn't he win an emmy he
was nominated for an emmy
no he is he's receiving an honorary emmy
andrew cuomo the deadliest governor on
kovid
that divergence is so great the way that
these things are being presented to you
and the reality of them so great the the
liberal left calling for
unity and healing joe biden saying the
democrats want unity and healing well
that woman
from michigan that state representative
cynthia johnson who yesterday called for
the murder
of trump supporters she has more
she's doubling down she wants to clarify
her comments listen
to this deranged rant all you soldiers
soldiers
of christ soldiers against racism
soldiers against misogyny
soldiers against domestic violence
and domestic terrorism
soldiers rise
it's time for you to rise
soldiers
soldiers for christ
hmm soldiers against racism
soldiers against misogyny
soldiers for
black and brown people who are being
mistreated rise
rise so on first glance
this woman is obviously a deranged
lunatic
this elected democrat is obviously
deranged
but there is a point to her deranged
rant
yesterday she had this video that said
trump supporters you better watch out
you better watch where you go soldiers
you know what to do
you know what to do take care of them be
in order
kill these guys that's what she's saying
she's saying murder trump supporters
and then she got in trouble for that and
then she was stripped of her committee
assignments
and she's she does this new video she
says soldiers
for christ and peace and stuff and
racism and anti-racism and you know
being good and
good soldiers who do things peacefully
you know
if that's what that woman meant in her
first video
when she called on trump supporters to
watch their backs and
said soldiers you know what to do we've
had enough we've had enough
uh i think she would have clarified that
i think she would have specified
that she was talking about soldiers for
christ and peace and
anti-racism and all that i don't think
that's what she was talking about i
think she got caught
calling for widespread violence against
trump supporters and now she's trying to
wiggle her way out of it
the same way a little kid who's got his
hand in the cookie jar is trying to
convince you that he's not taking a
cookie
but obviously that's not what she was
talking about even if
even if it were even if this second rant
represents her true views she's
obviously completely out of her mind
and should be removed certainly removed
from the michigan state house and
probably
probably investigated and prosecuted for
inciting violence
against trump supporters johnson is not
the only security risk
among democratic politicians you know
eric swalwell
had uh a lot of fun with some chinese
spies it would appear
i'll leave that vague i don't know what
kind of fun but he seems to have had a
lot of fun
we don't know how much how intimate but
we know they were connected okay
this makes him a security risk he's
obviously got to be kicked off the intel
committee he probably should be kicked
out of the house of representatives
nancy pelosi was asked about this she's
going to defend
the man who spent a whole lot of time
with the chinese spy
well i don't have any concern about mr
swarwell uh
there are those in the congress who
believe and i am among them
that we should be seeing what influenced
the chinese i've been
fighting them as you know for over 30
years i i do think
uh that it's unfortunate that mr
mccarthy is trying to make an
issue of this when his leader we all
found out at the same time
the republican leadership and that that
several members had been approached
but you know what he's trying to do he's
trying to deflect attention from the
fact
that he has cuein on in his uh his
delegation
over there q anon
hold on hold on uh one of your
democratic members
had a years-long financial and personal
and maybe a little very personal
relationship
with a chinese spy a known chinese spy
and that guy is sitting on the
intelligence committee
and that's not a big deal that's
actually that's just a distraction
from something on the internet
that no one would even have heard of had
the left not made a big issue out of it
the compromised security risk
blackmail asset who did lots of weird
stuff with a chinese spy
on the intel committee no big deal but a
thing
on some message boards somewhere on the
internet very very big deal
you have to laugh at it because it's so
brazen it's so disrespectful and there's
something very sad about that too
which is the left is convinced they've
won
and so they don't even need to try
anymore they don't even need to
pretend they can share yeah read about
hunter biden yeah oh
yes well well slept with the chinese spy
allegedly
okay what you know fine whatever yeah
it's not a big deal
nothing to see here move along move
along because
they feel they've won we'll find out if
they've won with this with this texas
uh lawsuit uh there's a a lot here i
mean you've got
uh briefings for the court from 17
states the president 106 house
republicans obviously the state of texas
it's a lot it's hard to get reading done
in our fast-paced world
at least it used to be but at
thinkor.org they summarized the key
ideas from new and noteworthy nonfiction
giving you access to an entire library
of great books in bite size form
read or listen to hundreds of titles in
a matter of minutes from old classics
like dale carnegie's how to win friends
and influence people
to recent best sellers like jordan
peterson's 12 rules for life
thinker offers a large variety of titles
across many categories from current
affairs
politics and business to education
history and relationships
you will even find titles from our very
own ben shapiro like the right side of
history or matt walsh's unholy trinity
or maybe even my book with words which
will be coming out
in just a matter of months six months
eight months something like that
i love thinkor they've been with me even
even before they were on this show they
were on my book club show at prageru
because they understand
the importance of reading if you want to
challenge your preconceptions
that's that's important expand your
horizons also important most importantly
most importantly sound smart at cocktail
parties go to thinkor.org that is
t-h-i-n-k-r
dot org no e no time for that start a
free trial download the app today
let them know you heard about them on
the michael knowles show that's
thinker.org
they're not even they're not even trying
anymore speaking of misdirections
from our political leaders the cdc
has some curious information out we're
in the peak of flu season right now this
is the beginning of peak flu season
and yet according to the cdc seasonal
influenza activity in the united states
remains lower than
usual for this time of year flu activity
is unusually low at this time but may
increase in the coming months
what's the model look like i mean what
can we see some charts and numbers and
stuff
no we can't actually because
flu hospitalizations are so low
that the cdc can't even model them
huh that's weird because we're
we're in the midst of this the worst
most terrible pandemic that's ever
afflicted mankind right according to the
left
coronavirus and
there's been some question about some of
these numbers that have come out about
coronavirus
and flew during peak flu season almost
doesn't exist
now why is that what the left will tell
you is
the reason there's a very clear reason
why flu numbers are so low
because we're wearing the masks and
the masks totally work you know that and
we're social distancing
and the measures that we've put into
place the measures
under president trump have been working
very very well oh wait a second
uh oh there's there's the problem
because while the left makes that
argument
that the reason flu numbers are so low
is because all these measures that have
been put into place for nine months have
worked very well
the left is simultaneously making the
argument that trump has completely
botched those measures that the way that
the masks and the lockdowns and the
the treatments have been implemented
have been haphazard and they haven't
worked
and people haven't even been abiding by
the guidelines and that's why
coronavirus numbers are spiking
because those measures haven't worked so
which is it
you can't have both you can't have both
the
very low number of flu hospitalizations
so low that you can't even model it has
to force the left
to give up one of those two arguments
they're not going to because they don't
care anymore because they don't feel
that they have to answer to anybody
because they think they've locked up at
least the next four years
but it it does show you the how
disingenuous they're being it does show
you
how unreliable the scientists and the
experts and the data are on this
doesn't make a lot of sense and you
don't need a lab coat and you don't need
all the degrees that dr fauci has
to know that you just need common sense
meanwhile the left is still using
all of these scientists and experts
to shut down the things we most cherish
and some of our most basic civil rights
and they're doing it in the name of
science
to mask the political arguments that
they're making best version of this the
other day and this guy knows a thing or
two about masking himself
is ralph northam in virginia governor of
virginia
is attacking people who go to church and
he's saying that people shouldn't go to
church you got to stay home
you can probably go to a blm rally you
can probably go loot the
local store in the name of justice you
can probably go to a politically correct
funeral
but not the funeral of your grandmother
and you certainly
can't go to church well here's
northam's argument he said is it the
worship or the building
you do not need to sit in the church
pews for god to hear your prayers
wow wow wow wow this
is obviously not a scientific statement
he's making it's a theological statement
and it's a very stupid one
just i'll just speak as a catholic here
we need
church buildings we need to go into the
confessional we need to receive the
blessed sacrament because
ours is an incarnational faith we need
to gather together doesn't matter let's
say you're not catholic let's say you're
you are the
least catholic protestant in the world
certainly you would agree we all have to
gather together
ralph northam says no you don't just not
just pray in your own mind that's it
that's all you have to do this is a
theological problem that began really in
earnest under the obama administration
because obama started to popularize this
phrase
a freedom of worship rather than freedom
of religion
freedom of religion implies that there's
a much broader public aspect to it
right and and we have religious freedom
in this country i don't just have the
freedom to think what i want in my head
which is by the way even that is
increasingly under attack but i have the
freedom
to enact my religion religion and faith
have a shape they look like something
they look like public practices they
look like public rituals they look like
public monuments for that matter
they look like build they look like
church buildings they look like people
gathering together
and that freedom of worship that changes
is no you're allowed to
believe whatever you want in the privacy
of your own little mind but there's no
public
public sense to that always
among the modern left science is invoked
as this category outside of politics
look we can have our religious disputes
we can have our political disputes but
let's put politics aside my friend nan
hayworth yesterday
pointed out that when someone tells you
let's put politics aside
you better have your politics ready to
go because they are about to inundate
you in a deluge of politics and they're
going to pretend it's not politics and
the way they've been doing it for at
least nine months now is they've been
saying
well it's science science says
you shouldn't go to church and you don't
have to to practice your faith ah no i
don't think science says that at all
i want you know what i want to do i want
to i want you to keep your science in
the privacy of your own home
capital s and the trademark over the e
and all the ways you manipulate the word
science i want you to keep that in the
privacy of your home okay
you do not need to come out in public to
practice your science governor northam
you can go and hide yourself at home and
i'm going to keep practicing my religion
as should we all that
will be something at least as as we have
so much uncertainty going into
this this next year that will be
something that we can enjoy sip those
leftist tears
ah yes that tastes like me practicing my
religion even if you persecute me
you got to get the leftist tumbler it's
new and improved stainless steel design
custom daily wire lid all dishwasher
safe very very
snazzy join daily wire now or upgrade
your membership to get yours just in
time
to enjoy all those salty left of steers
you know my show is five days a week
this is our second friday show we're
also going to radio in january
you now will get the entire prageru
catalog at dailywire.com by the end of
the year that includes prageru's
five-minute videos
that includes the candace owens show
from prageru and that includes
coincidentally the book club which is my
show at prageru
and the rest of the library is being
added as we speak plus
then early next year candace owens is
joining the daily wire here in nashville
where she will be launching a brand new
daily wire show in front of a live
studio audience
we're launching our first feature film
under daily wires upcoming entertainment
channel
we're building new investigative
journalism there's a lot going on guys
go to dailywire.com subscribe
we'll be right back with the mailbag
first question from bryson hey michael
do you think pastors should
this is funny timing on this question do
you think pastors should defy lockdown
orders and open their churches
my dad is a pastor in canada and he is
following the rules and leaving the
church closed
his reasons are one this is temporary
two churches are not being discriminated
against
all of manitoba is shut down with the
exception of essential businesses
three a five thousand dollar fine four
bad publicity what are your thoughts
yes open all the churches immediately
period simple as that i i think that
there
is a world in which it is legitimate for
churches to shut down for some period of
time for certain reasons
this is not one of those reasons this is
not that time
what are your dad's arguments this is
temporary is it
is it temporary on march 16th
i was told 15 days to slow the spread
march 15th so by
what is it oh it's uh
it's december and joe biden's promising
that it's going to go on for another 100
days if he's sworn in on january 20th
so it's not temporary this is going to
be temporary forever
two churches are not being discriminated
against they are they are because you're
saying all of manitoba's shut down with
the exception of essential businesses so
hold on hold on a second
some i'll just use the example of the
united states because i'm more familiar
with the way that's playing out here
in the united states in california
certain marijuana dispensaries were
considered essential but churches closed
certain liquor stores certain
restaurants considered essential
but church is closed essential
refers to whatever standard your society
has
and in our very liberal secular
materialist society
frivolous things are considered
essential and
church is considered non-essential
i don't think that's true i think church
is the most essential institution
there is i think not only the country
but the whole
civilization will go to hell in a hand
basket if you close the churches for too
long
and i don't care if you've got to close
the head shop or you've got to close the
liquor store and i really like liquor
too but i
i don't care because that's not the most
important institution
so the church is being discriminated
against they're just pretending it's not
because they're using these guys of
signs
five thousand dollar fine yeah that's
too bad maybe you don't have the money
then you can't open up but if you can
i'd open up
for bad publicity bad publicity for whom
that would be very good publicity if i
were reading that story
i would consider that to be a very good
and brave thing it's only bad publicity
if the people who are
who you're appealing to are squishes and
have the wrong ideas
open up from binyamin hi michael
long time listener to the show my
question is this over the past four
years the israeli government has tied
itself more and more to the republican
party
completely alienating the democrats in
the house and senate do you think this
will have
an effect on the biden administration's
foreign policy assuming of course biden
becomes president specifically regarding
the iran deal and future peace deals
between arab countries and israel
even not outright but behind the scenes
hurting israel thank you for all the
amazing content hashtag michael knowles
international thank you ben you mean
yes uh it will it will affect that and
yes you're right israel has tied itself
more to the republican party
than to the democratic party i don't
think this is israel's fault i don't
think this is the republican party's
fault
i don't think israel left the democratic
party
i think the democratic party left israel
i think all of the aggression came from
the democrats
as they cozied up to radicals who don't
think that israel has a right to exist
bibi netanyahu is a smart guy he's tried
to play nice and he's tried to play well
with people
and notably barack obama completely
turned
on him and on israel through israel
under the bus notably with the iran deal
but other
other measures as well and so israel
did the only thing it could do which was
turn more to the republican party and
they've done a great job doing that
and now there's going to be some effect
of that i don't think that could have
been avoided though i don't think there
was any smarter way
for israel to play it they played the
hand that was dealt to them
and trump has dealt justly with them and
obama dealt unjustly with them and
you're going to have more radical
leftists
going after israel if joe biden becomes
president
and i don't think that any amount of
sucking up or appeasement would convince
them otherwise
from them hey michael i love your show
in fact i love all the daily wire shows
i've listened for a while and i find it
interesting that you all have different
beliefs in religion
how often does religion come up with the
other hosts of the daily wire
and do you usually end agreeing or
disagreeing thanks
it comes up all the time it is all we
talk about even when we start talking
about other things we end up talking
about religion
here you've got ben is an orthodox jew
i'm a catholic
matt walsh is a catholic uh drew
is an anglican i guess you'd like sort
of an anglo-catholic but he's
definitively on the protestant side of
that he's you know church of england-ish
uh jeremy is a protestant as he likes to
describe he is
as protestant as they come so sort of
non-denominational
protestant and we we always and we
usually end up disagreeing that
we find areas of agreement and then we
find areas of disagreement because
as cardinal manning pointed out all
human conflict
is ultimately theological all of our
debates about coronavirus are
they are theological because they're
really debates about the lockdowns and
the lockdowns are really debates about
what we value in society
and the way that we view the human
person and the way we view
life so those are those boil down to
theological debates the problem is
the notably the left has lost the
theological and philosophical
sophistication
to have those debates so they don't even
know that they're having them when they
are
but we talk about it all the time it's
ultimately it's sort of the only thing
worth talking about
and when we're having sort of cultural
discussions which are lovely and
political discussions and discussions
about the food even
very often that will refer in some
sometimes hidden way to a theological
grounding
from cheryl hello from the lone star
state
do you believe that some companies and
stores will require proof of vaccine
trying to remain practical and believe
this is not to be a possibility in
america however
do you believe all covid related
mandates will end as the vaccine will be
available in texas soon just want your
opinion on whether proof of vaccine or
wearing masks forever
is or is not a possibility love the work
you do at daily wire thank you
it's a distinct possibility it's not
just a possibility it's already
happening
in the united kingdom wales is already
implementing
measures that are leaning in this
direction and the united states
certainly could i don't think it's
inevitable that it happens in the united
states
but i think we need to push back on it
very very hard i
fully intend to do that and i think
i think everyone else should as well the
one that's going to be really tricky
is going to be travel if you can't get
on an airplane
without proof of the vaccine that's
going to be very difficult
because for some people their jobs are
for my job i have to get on airplanes
there isn't time to take a train or to
drive places and
look maybe you'll have trains
implementing this kind of policy too who
knows
it's certainly possible people have not
only advocated it but it is happening
elsewhere in the world
and that's a very bad idea and i don't
want to go along with it and i know
texas has a rebellious spirit as we're
seeing play out at the court right now
so i suggest you not go along with those
sorts of
commercial and governmental mandates
either
it's not saying don't get the vaccine i
think they're good arguments to get the
vaccine
but don't go along with any of those
mandates from zack
michael one of the key things i've
learned since listening to the daily
wire is the importance of words
and defining terms and discussions i was
wondering if you could help me clarify
the following to be more effective
when are the proper times to use liberal
progressive libertarian
and conservative should classical
liberal be a separate category or
political ideology from the others
i wish there was a simple right or left
spectrum but i believe there were more
nuances to consider thank you for all
you do
in putting kofi in my coffee the first
thing i would recommend you do
is get specific about what you're
talking about i mean i think that's kind
of the premise of your question anyway
but even beyond these labels sometimes
these labels are not particularly
helpful
because when i say libertarian and when
somebody else is libertarian we might be
referring to different things
and we might both have a point but it i
think it helps to get even more granular
than that what issue are we talking
about what stance are we talking about
how will this work in reality one great
thing about conservatives
is that we're not metaphysical abstract
people all the time with our heads in
the hair and never looking down to
planet earth
we want to know how things work in
practice with prudence
those are not bad they're bad words to
the ideologues but they're not bad words
to us
so just broadly liberalism refers to
the political philosophies that
developed in
largely in the 17th and 18th centuries
um this then splits off and there's a
sort of right liberalism
which now we usually call libertarianism
although there isn't left libertarianism
too
and then there's a left liberalism which
develops in the
19 late 19th early 20th centuries into
progressivism
progressivism is uh in
some ways a natural outgrowth of
liberalism because
it's a rationalist political ideology
that says basically we need to get rid
of the
sort of robust political debate that we
have we need to ignore the eternal laws
of the universe
upon which our constitution is is
grounded and we need to move into the
world of evolution and progress
and darwin and recognize that human
nature can change and we need to
take politics away from the people and
give it to the scientific experts you're
seeing that play out
as well whereas the libertarians modern
libertarians
kind of take the older liberalism which
you might call classical liberalism
and then they've just read too much iron
rand or something and you know
uh they watched a lot of milton friedman
videos and
so they are it is still distinct from
from uh classical classical liberalism
in the way that it's practiced in the
united states but it tends to be a
little more right-wing
but it's still uh all of those sorts of
ideologies have
i think an incorrect view of human
nature the human person
they they all seem to posit that the
individual is the basic building block
of society
whereas conservatives disagree with that
conservatives tend to believe that the
family is the basic building block of
society
liberals of all sorts the right ones the
left ones the libertarians the
progressives
they tend to believe that uh we ought to
look at politics primarily through a
lens of rights
i think that we as conservatives think
that we should look at politics
primarily through a lens of
duty loyalty gratitude obligation
prudence
providence taking the inherited wisdom
of the past and taking it seriously
uh and so when you but i i say that even
the left and right versions of
liberalism
call it progressivism libertarianism
whatever they take the individual
and then on the left they take all those
individuals and bunch them up together
and you have collectivist politics and
on the right-wing version of liberalism
they just keep the the individual
atomized so you know it's this
sort of classic idea of it's it's all
just about me and i'll do whatever i
want i can exert my will however i want
pursue my appetites and
and you can't say nothing about it and
then you see in the idea of bunching up
individuals into the collective you you
uh that's where you get the actually the
word fascism comes from the idea of the
foshi yeah did you bundle up all these
sticks together
and then you've got the nation uh you
get obviously communism from that you
get socialism from that
and then you get the atomized
individuals too and i just think all of
those kind of miss the mark
and that's why we ought to all be
conservatives
from tim i'll take one more if biden is
elected can we not sue the dnc for
putting up a candidate who knowingly had
a condition
that would keep him from finishing his
term can the senate do
something thanks no we can't
we can't i hate to tell you that but we
can't
as i think we've all learned over the
past several weeks if we didn't know it
before
elections are extraordinarily messy
i i keep going back to lyndon johnson
who stole the 1948 senate seat in texas
and by the time people really figured it
out he was already dead
he'd already been senator vice president
president already transformed the
country
there were irregularities
and outright crimes in certain places in
certain key
states that may well have changed the
results
in those states i really have no doubt
about that
i have no doubt that machine-run
democrat cities
did lots of illegal things
the trouble is there's a process and so
the states are going to certify those
votes they're probably going to send
electors the electors are going to vote
so that's that's kind of the left-wing
argument is or the the pro-biden
argument is that's the process haha
sorry even if there was election fraud
doesn't matter or he's the president
now the the right-wing version is okay
yeah okay you're gonna
have your shenanigans well we're gonna
fight this in court tooth and nail
and we're gonna fight challenge the
pennsylvania
constitution and on the basis of the
constitution
we're going to have texas sue other
states we're going to have other states
join in and the president and 106 house
members
and then the left yells this is
unconstitutional this is unfair this is
fraudulent this is terrible no i don't
think i think it's
great i think it's fabulous i think it
would be absolutely terrific
if the supreme court would weigh in and
say okay texas you got it
trump's the president i think that would
be terrific and perfectly legitimate
and perfectly constitutional the court
has signaled
probably it's not going to do that hope
springs eternal in the human breast
but both of those views the pro-biden
view and the pro-trump view will
culminate in the reality of the
messiness of elections
that the electors are going to vote and
whoever they vote for
is going to be the president and it
doesn't
really even matter quite how they got
there that
is the process and we can be thrilled
about it and the left can be screaming
about it or the left can be thrilled
about it and we can be screaming about
it
but it doesn't change the fact that that
is the process and we're going to know a
whole lot more about that
maybe momentarily so we'll just have to
wait to discuss it until monday have a
good weekend i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadovsky editor and associate
producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20. you know the
matt wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll give it a listen
you